ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนซอยนี้
ค่ะนักเรียนน้องก็กลับมาเจอกับครูหญิงเรา
ก็ครูฟ้าฟ้านะคะในวีดีโอระดับอะไรคะระดับ
บีกินเนอร์ค่ะ bi เออ
ครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันพฤหัสบดีที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพฤหัสบดีที่
31 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคม
ปีพตตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ผักค่ะเมื่อวานวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 30 เดือน
มีนาคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
32 ไม่มี
เดือนอะไรคะเมษายน
ปีพตค 2556  5 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะ
อ่ะแต่ตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 น
11:00 นกี่นาที
21 นาที
11:21 นาทีนะคะก็เป็นเวลากลางวัน
น้องกลางวันนะคะก็ครูบากับครูหญิงเนี่ยก็
ทำงานแล้วใช่ไหมกลางวันเนี่ยปะสอนนัก
เรียนใช่ไหมคะในวีดีโอแล้วก็จะไปกินข้าว
หรอแต่ว่าครูฟ้าละเวลาที่เราสองคนเนี่ยมี
Video  Class ใช่ไหมมี Video  Class นัก
เรียนเนี่ยดูดูเรา
เรียนเราก็จะเห็นป่าครูหญิงกากครูฟ้า
เนี่ยมีสี
เห็นไหมอ่ะเนี่ยก็ไม่เห็น
นักเรียนซูมเข้ามานะคะปากใช่มั้ยปากน้าสี
ชมพูนะคะฟ้ามีสีชมพูอยู่ที่ปากอ่าทำไมอ่ะ
ทำไมครุฟ้าชิสีชมพูที่ปากครูฟ้าชาลิปสติก
เหรอคะ
ทาลิปสติกเหนื่อยมีลิปสติกสมัยที่เป็น
ลิปสติกแบบจิ้มจุ่มนะคะกูฟ้าก็มีลิปสติก
ใช่ไหมคะเราก็ถาม
ฐาน
ไทยห่าครูฟ้าอ่ะทาลิปสติกนะคะนักเรียนค่ะ
ครูคุณวริติกคลิปสิกติดฟันได้ถ้านักเรียน
เอ้าฟรี
ร้านค้าทาลิปสติกครูหญิงก็ทาลิปสติก
นักเรียนธาริตติกไหม
เออไม่รู้ถ้าเป็นเออประเทศไทยเนี่ยนะคะ
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงไทยธาริตสิโกโอเคแต่ผู้ชาย
ไทย
ผู้ชายไทยชาลิปสิกและ
หน่อยค่ะนิดหน่อยหน่อยหน่อยหน่อยเพราะว่า
ไม่โอเคนะคะผู้หญิงทาลิปสติกโอเคผู้ชาย
ทาลิปสติกโอเคของผู้ชายอันนี้ผู้หญิงผู้
หญิงผู้ชายโอเคแต่ถ้าผู้ผู้หญิงเนี่ยบาง
คนเนี่ยไม่ได้ทาลิปสติกอย่างเดียวผู้หญิง
สมัยครูหญิงก็ได้นะครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่ได้ทาลิปสติกนะครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ผู้แต่งหน้านะคะแต่งหน้าที่นักเรียนเห็น
เนี่ยไม่ใช่หน้าที่คุยอิ๋งตื่นนอนมาแล้ว
ก็สวัสดีค่ะไม่ใช่
รูหญิงแน่นะคะ
ตื่นนอน
7:00 นสวยเนี่ยตื่นมา 7:00 นอามน้ำแปลง
ฟันใส่เสื้อเสร็จก็แต่งหน้าน้องแต่งหน้า
จนถึงเจ็ดโมงเนี่ย 40 สวยหา
มี 10 นาที 40 นาทีเนี่ยอาบน้ำแปรงฟัน
แต่งหน้าจะผู้หญิงเนี่ยแต่งหน้าไอ้ผู้
หญิงส่วนใหญ่แต่งหน้านะคะเพราะว่าเวลามา
สอนใน YouTube ใช่ไหมสีฟ้าผู้หญิงบาท
วีดีโอเนี่ยนักเรียนจะได้ไม่อา
ชุบกูฟ้ากับผู้หญิงก็แต่งน่าจะโอเคใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะนี่ไงนี่ไงนี่ไงปีหารูปแต่งหน้าให้
นักเรียนรู้
เรียนรู้แล้ว
ผู้หญิงไม่ต้องหานะผมรู้
เจอไหมคะให้เจอแล้วค่ะครูฟ้านี่ค่ะครุฑ
แต่งหน้าได้มันครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าเนี่ยแต่ง
หน้า
แล้วเรียนถามแต่งหน้าแล้วหรอทำไมเหมือน
ไม่ได้แต่ง
แต่งแล้วค่ะสมัยอย่างครูครูฟ้านะแต่งหน้า
ใช่ไหมครูหญิงเนี่ยแต่งหน้าก็เวลาที่แต่ง
หน้ามันก็ต้องมีแบบของใช่ไหมที่เราเรียก
ว่าเครื่องสำอางตอนนี้ไม่ว่าจะเป็นแบบนี้
แบบนี้
อันนี้
ทั้งหมดที่
เครื่องสำอางเครื่องสำอางค่ะเครื่องซึ่ง
อาผู้หญิงมีเครื่องสำอางใช่ไหมค่ะครูฟ้า
มีไหมฟ้ามีเครื่องสำอางนะคะ
นิดหน่อยนะคะ
นิดหน่อย
เรียนไม่ได้เยอะมาก
เครื่องสำอางผู้หญิง
นุ่มถุง
หนึ่งถุง
งั้นเดี๋ยวครูหญิงก็จะมาถามครูฟ้าและกัน
นะคะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยมีเครื่องสำอางอะไร
แล้วก็แต่งหน้าอะไรบ้างอย่างครูหญิงเนาะ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยนะคะตัดเจ็บที่ 1 มีใครดีก็
จะหน้าใสๆค่ะใช้ค่ะผู้หญิงก็จะมีรองพื้น
นะคะอันนี้ไหมอ่ะรองพื้นใช่มั้ยคุณก็คือ
อาบน้ำแล้วก็ล้างหน้าไม่มีอะไรกินก็มีรอง
พื้นกับคูชั่นคนไทยก็เรียกครูชั่นนะคะนัก
เรียน
นี่หรอ
คูชั่นสกปรกนะคะได้เปลี่ยนน้ำมันก็เส้น
แบบนี้จะเป็นแบบนี้ครูสั้นนะคะครูฟ้า
เนี่ยทารองพื้นแล้วก็คือกฎสมัยกดแล้วก็
แล้วก็ทาทารองพื้นหรือว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยใช้
คูชั่นจะมาแล้วก็
จบคูชั่นไหมคะเอเอ
ทารองพื้นดี
ตกคูชั่นไทยได้ตบกูชั่น
a ค่ะผู้หญิง 5 รองพื้นค่ะทารองและ
ก็จะมีรองพื้นนะคะแล้วก็ทา
ถ้าร้องพื้นถ้านักเรียนไม่ฟ้าชาลีฝืนไป
นักเรียนดู
จะโอเคไหมนะ
ถ้าลองยื่น
ป.ป.ช.จะเตะที่ 1 ใช่ไหมกูฟ้าทารองพื้น
ทั้งหน้าสมัยทั้งหน้าใครค่ะทารองพื้นทั้ง
หน้าเลยนะเกลียด
อออควบครูหญิงเนี่ยทุกวันเนี่ยไม่ได้ทา
ร้องอื่นนะครูหญิงเนี่ยตบคูชั่นค่ะคูชั่น
มีพับมีพับแล้วก็กดลงไปที่ผู้ใช่แล้วก็ตก
มันไม่ได้ยินเสียงหรอกน้องหอมคุณสั้นหอม
มากนะคะผู้ฉันเกาหลีนะคะอ่ะ for คุณฟ้าทา
รองพื้นคะแล้วก็ตบคูชั่นเสร็จแล้วสเต็ป
ที่ 2 เนี่ยก็คือมีแป้งนะคะแป้งครูหญิง
เนี่ยวิ่ง
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีแป้งฝุ่นไม่เรียนเห็นไหมคะ
แป้งฝุ่นแป้งฝุ่นเพราะว่ามันเป็นเหมือน
ฝุ่นพูดเล่นพูด
ฝุ่นหักฝุ่น
ฝุ่นฮ่ะเห็นอ่ะ
อุ้ยกับคอมพิวเตอร์พังนะคะแป้งฝุ่นหรอครู
หญิงแม่นภาก็จะมีแรงน้ำมีแปลงและก็เอา
แปรงเนี่ยแต่แป้งฝุ่นแล้วก็ปัด
ม้า
รู้ฟ้ามีแป้งไหมคะ
ไม่มี
รูฟ้าไม่ทาแป้ง
ไม่ไม่ถามแป้งค่ะนี่กูคะมีแป้งรอแป๊บนึง
นะได้ค่ะ
ครูบามีแป้งอะไร
แป้งเด็กแล้วชายยังไงภูฟ้าใช้แปลงไหมใช้
แปรงทาไหมใช้มือ
ต่อเทแป้งใส่มือแล้วทำยังไงอ่ะ
ก็โง่ถาแป้งต่อ 2 ฝาก็ถามแป้งใช้มือทามือ
ทาแป้งเด็กอันนี้คือแป้งเด็กนะเราเรียก
แป้งดิ
ก็ปัดแป้งเสร็จแล้วครูฟ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยก็
จะเขียนคิ้วนะมีดินสอเขียนคิ้วแล้วก็
เขียนคิ้ว
เขียนคิ้วนะฮะเขียนคิดว่าต้องเอาแว่นออก
ก่อนนะคะเขียนคิวครูฟ้าเขียนคิ้วไหมคะอ่ะ
ที่เขียนคิ้วหครูป๊ามีดินสอเขียนคิ้ว
ดินสอนะคะนักเรียนเป็น
อยู่หรอเขียนคิ้วให้ไหมแล้วก็
วิวสวยนะเวลาผู้หญิงเขียนคิ้วเถอะ
เขียนคิ้วแล้วเอาไปให้เขียนคิ้วเท่านัก
เรียนดินสอนหิว
เขียนคิ้วใช่ไหมคะอ่าพอเขียนคิ้วเสร็จ
แล้วครูหญิงนั้นของครูหญิงนะคะครูหาก็จะ
มี
อายแชโดว์เรื่องอะไรอายแชโดว์
สีทาตาภาษาไทยก็คือที่ทาตาใช้อันนี้ของ
ผู้หญิงนะเป็นแบบนี้ไม่มีกริตเตอร์ไม่ผู้
หญิงก็จะมีแรงแต่ไม่ใช่แปลงอันนี้นะคะนัก
เรียน
นี่ค่ะมีแรงอาคาตามาแล้วก็จิ้มที่สี
แต่ก็เคาะนิดหน่อยนะคะเหมือนอยู่ตีปลอก
เอ้อแล้วก็ทาตาทา
หน้าตาครูฟ้าเนี่ยทาตาไหมคะหรือว่าแต่งตา
ไหมแต่งตาก็คือมีอายแชโดว์ทาใช่มั้ยทาน
เสร็จแล้วก็มีกลิตเตอร์แล้วก็
หน้าแต่งตานะไม่สวยนะครูฟ้าแต่งตาไหมฟ้า
มีอายที่ทาตานะคะที่รับอ่านะฮะมันก็ต้อง
มีใช้นิ้วได้ไหมขอใช้ได้บ้างบางคนไม่ใช้
แปรงสมัยแปลงเนี่ยไม่ใซ้เอาเคยฟ้าใช้นิ้ว
แต่งตาไทยหาใช้นิ้วแต่งตานะคะอยู่ที่ทาพา
ซีอิ๊วแล้วก็ทาอ๋อพอ
หน้าตาเสร็จเนี่ยก็จะต้องมีมีขนตาใช่ไหม
ที่ตาก็จะมีขนตา
ฮะ
มีอายไลเนอร์ด้วยผู้หญิงไม่มีครูฟ้าทำ
อะไรคะอายไลเนอร์อะไรน่อเนี่ยภาษาอังกฤษ
นะคะคุณไทยพูดอายไลเนอร์ภาษาไทยก็คือ
อายไลเนอร์นะคะอะไรไม่อยากเราพูดว่ากรีด
ตา
ไม่ฟ้ากรีดตาใช้อะไรน่อกรีดตาไอ้ๆอะไรน่อ
กรีดปลาค่ะนั้นเวียนฉแต่นี้ไม่ได้นะโชว์
โชว์ไม่ได้ยาก
อ๋อนี่ครูฟ้ากำลังใช้อายไลเนอร์กรีดตาให้
นักเรียนรู้เห็นมั้ยกูว่าจะมีหนึ่งข้างนะ
คะ
กรีดปลาให้นักเรียนกรีดตายนะค่ะจะเอาครู
หญิงไม่มีแล้วทำไม่มีอายไลเนอร์ผู้หญิง
ไหมกรีดตานะคะไม่แต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยจะดัดขน
ตานี้ใช่ไหมอ่าอันนี้นะคะขนตานะขนตาผู้
หญิงก็จะมี
ที่ดัดขนตาที่ดัดขนตาและปิดต้องถอดแว่นนะ
คะแล้วก็
แล้วก็ดัดใช่ไหมดัดขนตา
ดัดผลตาครูฟ้าดัดขนตาไหมคะ
รูปฟ้า /
ป่านดัดครู
นกรูมาก็มีที่ดัดขนตาแล้วก็ดัดขนตาใช้ขน
ตามันก็จะแบบนี้เพราะกูฟ้าดัดก็จะมีงอนนะ
คะคนจะงอนอ่า
อันนี้ครูปลาครับ
อ่าพอดัดขนตาเสร็จทำไมครูหญิงเนี่ยก็จะมี
มาสคาร่าหนา
มาสคาร่า
5 แล้วก็ปัดก็จะต้องปัดขนตาเหรอคุยก็จะ
มองไม่เห็นอ้ะปัดขนตาใช่ไหมปัดขนตา
ครูฟ้าตัดขนตาไหมคะมีมาสคาร่าแล้วก็ปัดขน
ตาไฟฟ้ามีมาสคาร่ากูฟ้าปัดขนตา
ไฟฟ้าปัดขนตาบนขนตาล่าง 2 ที่เลยไหมคะขน
ตาบน
ฝันเพราะว่าอันนี้ตา
ฉันก็จะมีขนตาบนขนตาล่างครูหญิงเนี่ยปัด
ขนตาบนไม่ต่อขนตาล่าง
ใช่ค่ะปัดขนตาบนค่ะปัดขนตาบนนะขนตาล่าง
ไม่ปัดนะคะ
ปัดขนตาเสร็จนะครูหญิงเนี่ยก็จะมี
เท่าไหร่คะครูฟ้าอะไรคะ
ที่ปัดแก้ม
ที่ปรัชญ์แก้มจะแต่ครูหญิงนะคะใช้ที่ปัด
แก้มที่เป็น Cream เป็นครีมไม่ได้เห็น
เป็น kreme ไม่ใช่เป็นฝุ่นครูฟ้ามีแบบ
ครีมหรือว่าแบบฝุ่นฟ้ามีแบบเป็นปุ่นค่ะ
นี่เป็นปุ่นผู้หญิงเนี่ยเป็นครีมนักเรียน
เห็นไหมมันจะเหมือนมีน้ำตาเป็นครีม
นั่นแหละคุยก็ใช้แบบครีมนะคะแล้วและก็มี
แปรงปัดแก้มในเอาแปลงเนี่ย
จุ่มลงไปที่ครีมแลก็
หัว
อัดที่เกม
แล้วก็ปัดแก้มนะคะเอาปัดที่แก้มแล้วพี่ก็
จะปัดที่ปลายจมูกเร็วๆลายสมุดเราก็ตัดถุง
นี่ค่ะปลายจมูกใช่ไหมปัดที่ปลายจมูกปัด
แก้มคุยสัมผัสแก้มตรงนี้นะคะที่เป็นหน้า
แก้มปัดแก้มครูค่ะโหแก้ม
กูฟ้าปัดแก้มยังไงกูเขาก็จะมีแปลงค่ะ
แม่อะไร
แล้วก็จะใช้แปลงเรียกอะไรอ่ะแตะอ่ะตั้ง
แต่ที่
Brush  on นะคะ
แล้วคะ
ก็ปัดแก้วออแล้วครูบาปปัดที่ปลายจมูกไหม
ตรงนี้ปลายจมูก
ปลายจมูกไม่หัก
ปัดแก้มปัดแก้ม
ปัดแก้มแล้วนะค่ะอ่ะผู้หญิงบางวันเนี่ย
ครูป๊าครูหญิงก็ไม่ได้ใช้ต่อแบบครีมมี
ผู้หญิงใช้อะไรผู้หญิงใช้ที่เป็นน้ำเป็น
หลอดอันนี้ก็เป็น bus  on นะคะเป็นหลอด
แต่ว่าอันนี้สีสดๆไม่ตัดให้ดูนะคะว่าแต่
ว่าเวลาบีบ
ออกมาเนี่ยมันไม่ได้เป็นครีมอ้ะ
มันจะเป็นน้ำ
เห็นหน้าไม่ถูกนี่นะคะมันจะเป็นน้ำใช่ไหม
เวลาปัดปัดป่ะเนี่ย
มันจะเป็นน้ำ
อยู่ไหนคะนี่ค่ะมิสมี 2 แบบไม่มีแบบฝุ่น
นะคะไม่ตัดนะคะพอแล้วแดงแล้วนะคะอ่ะพ่อ
มึงผู้หญิงปัดแก้มเสร็จนะคะครูฟ้าคุยก็
ขั้นตอนสุดท้ายแล้วค่ะธาริตติก R มี
ลิปสติกและทาลิปสติกนะใครล่ะนิติอยู่ไหน
อ่ะต่ายครูหญิงเนี่ยมีลิปสติกที่เป็น
แข้งสวยเป็นแท่งแบบนี้
แล้วก็มีวันนี้เขาเรียกอะไรแรงปะแรงแรง
เเล้วก็ที่ปากเลยอ่ะ
คะแล้วก็จะมีรีบสิกที่เป็นเรื่องอะไร
อย่างเงี้ย
แห้งแห้งแล้วก็มีแบบนี่นะเวลาหมุนขึ้นมา
มาก็จะเป็นแบบนี้
แบบนี้นะคะแล้วก็ทามีสองอย่าง
ครูฟ้ามีลิปสติกแต่ว่ามีลิปสติกหลายหลาย
สี
ในอ่าสีแดง
สีส้มไปสมแบบส้มเลยนะ
มาสีส้มจะมีเยอะๆนะครูฟ้าทาลิปสติกใช่ไหม
คะให้หาครูฟ้าทาลิปสติกดึงไฟถ้ายังไงครู
หญิงเนี่ยทาเสร็จแล้วก็เม้มปาก
ครูฟ้าก็ทาลิปสติกทาลิปสติกแล้วก็มีอ้า
ปาก
เหมือนกันนะคะ
พอหมดแล้วเสร็จหรือยังครูฟ้าเสร็จหรือยัง
ครูหญิงเสร็จแล้วหมดแล้วเสร็จแล้วค่ะนัก
เรียนเสร็จแล้วไม่มีอะไรเนี่ยแต่งหน้า
เสร็จแล้วนักเรียนเห็นตอนต้นวีดีโอครู
หญิงกับครูฟ้ายังไม่ได้แต่งหน้าตอนนี้
แก้มสีแดงปากสีแดงคิวสวย
ตาสวย
ใช่ไหมคะเราเป็นผู้หญิงเราก็เลยแต่งหน้า
นะเราก็เลยมาทำให้นักเรียนดูนะคะต้องค่ะ
วันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วนั้นตรีเรียนเราก็ไป
แบบสวยๆนะคะแล้วเจอกัน bdo หน้าบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ